الاليات العسكريه تقتحم مدينه
جنين عبوات ناسفه فجرها مقاومون في بعض
هذه الاليات في حي
الجابريات عمليه اسفرت عن مقتل مجنده في
الوحدات الخاصه في حرس الحدود بعد دقائق
وخلال تغطيه الجزيره عمليه الاقتحام سمع
صوت اطلاق قذائف من طائره مسيره ولكن الان
سمع من الان اصوات اشتباكات مجددا ولكن
يبدو انها يعني اشتباكات عنيفه وبعد بضع
ساعات وعقب انسحاب قوات الاحتلال تبين ان
سبعه شبان استهدفتهم الصواريخ في حي مثلث
الشهداء الذي يبعد بضعه كيلومترات عن موقع
الاقتحام
الاسرائيلي نقلوا اشلاء الى المستشفى من
بينهم اربعه اشقاء ام
كان يفترض ان ياتي نجلها الاكبر الى
المستشفى لجلسه علاج مرض الكلى الله يرحم
الله يغفرلهم ويرضى عليهم الله يرضى
عليهم الله يرضى عليهم احنا مش احسن من
غزي غزي قاعدين بموت كلهم كلهم كل يوم
بموت بغزي كل
يوم الحمد لله رب العالمين الحمد لله يهم
لما بدنا وطن بدنا نتحمل كل شي فانطلقت
جنازه
غاضبه جبت شوارع مدينتي ومخيم جنين حتى
وصلت الى حي مثلث الشهداء جنوبي
المدينه مقاومون يطلقون الرصاص في الهواء
حزنا
وغضبا يؤكدون انهم سيواصلون طريق المقاومه
موحدين في الميدان نحن يد واحده ورسالتنا
اليوم للاحتلال لكافه وزراء الاحتلال بمن
فيهم نتنياهو وسموت وكل من قام على هذا
على حكومه الاحتلال النازيه سنقول لهم
اننا مواصل الدرب ولن نتخلى ولن نحيد هو
مشهد وداع اخر عاشته اكثر من 80 عائله
فلسطينيه في جنين من بين اكثر من 320
شهيدا سقطوا في الضفه الغربيه منذ بدء
الحرب
الاسرائيليه على
غزه لا يمر يوم دون مواكب شهداء تسير في
شوارع الضفه الغربيه والمقاومون يؤكدون
استمرار تصديهم للاحتلال وتطوير اساليب
مقاومتهم حتى الوصول الى الحريه جف
البديري الجزيره جنوبي
جنين